- [Crowd] 12, 11, 10,
- So June 29th, 2007, we were excited.
We were terrified.
- [Woman] nine, eight, seven,
- It's a happy moment, but
it's also a stressful one.
What's gonna happen when
it goes out into the world?
- [Crowd] six, five,
- You don't know what's about to come.
This is a totally new experience
and something that's gonna
change our lives forever.
- [Crowd] four, three,
(rousing orchestral music)
- It was amazing.
I mean, it still just kinda gives me
a little bit of goosebumps
because it was history.
- [Crowd] two, one.
(crowd cheers)
- [Jason] A lot of nervousness,
a lot of stomach ache,
a lot of excitement.
(Lauren laughs)
(crowd cheers)
- I'm Lauren Schmick.
- And I'm Jason Schmick.
- And our son, Noah, was born
the same day the very
first iPhone was released.
- [Joanna] This is the
story of the iPhone baby
and how 15 years shaped a generation.
(orchestral music)
Try to remember life before the iPhone.
It's hard,
but Noah Schmick literally can't
because, well, he's never
lived a day in the world
without an iPhone.
But this isn't just about one teenager
who shares his birthday
with a world-changing piece
of glass and metal.
- I used to post this on
your birthday every year.
It's because it's Steve Jobs
wishing you a happy birthday.
Because look at it,
you got the cake and
your birthday down there.
- [Noah] The whole numbers right there.
It's personalized.
- [Jason] He cared.
(Lauren chuckles)
- [Joanna] This is about
how, over the last 15 years,
the iPhone itself went
from a baby to a teen.
As it grew and developed,
so did our dependence on it.
Noah's generation is the
most extreme representation
of that dependence
because they've never
known life without it.
It's a generation that
fears being disconnected.
- This is everything you'd ever need
in the palm of your hands.
Why would you never be off of it?
They have the sum of the
world's entire knowledge
and all of your closest people
instantly available to talk to.
If you gave this thing to a caveman,
they'd freak out.
- [Joanna] Of course today,
it's not just the iPhone,
it's all smartphones.
- [Voiceover 1] Galaxy S22
Ultra breaks all the rules
of what a smartphone can do.
- [Joanna] Legacy phone makers,
such as Samsung, Nokia,
and Blackberry creator RIM,
were forced to adapt
or die after the
introduction of the iPhone.
- [Voiceover 2] So you thought Blackberrys
were all business.
- [Joanna] while it was Google's
Android operating system
- [Robotic voiceover] Droid.
- [Joanna] combined with
more affordable phones
from Samsung and others
that captured the biggest
global market share,
it was Apple's iPhone
that really kicked off
the mobile revolution.
So I set out to pinpoint
the major developments
to the iPhone that led to that dependence
with exclusive access to Apple executives,
past and present, who made
this revolutionary product.
Alongside those conversations,
I went to Wisconsin.
Hi! Joanna.
And I traced the story of Noah,
his twin 13-year-old siblings,
and his parents.
Just like millions of other families,
Apple's invention made them more connected
and disconnected in
ways no one anticipated.
(light music)
- Look!
Baby's first picture.
And this blob is his head.
- But look, he has his hand up by his face
and that's exactly how he was born,
with his hand.
- [Joanna] While Noah was in development,
Apple was developing its own baby
over 21,000 miles away.
- The start of the iPhone project happened
from the iPod project.
We started seeing these feature phones
with cameras starting to
add digital music features.
- [Voiceover 3] A hundred
tunes in your phone, baby,
- [Voiceover 4] Hello, Moto.
- And it was clear at some point
they might be able to catch up with us
with this lead that we had
with the iPod.
- [Voiceover 5] Imagine a phone that is
all music on one side
and all talk on the other
just like you.
- A mobile phone wanted
to have everything.
It wanted to be all-in-one device.
At the time, we were also saying,
"Okay, what is the future of the iPod?
And if people have two
devices in their hands,
which one would they pick up every time?"
- [Joanna] After Tony
Fadell co-invented the iPod,
Steve Jobs had a new task for him
and a few others in early 2005,
figure out what an Apple
phone would look like.
- One was a iPod plus phone,
which looked like an iPod Classic.
It had the wheel on it.
We tried for weeks, six, eight weeks,
to try to crack the code on that.
We couldn't make it work.
There was another project we
were doing in the iPod team.
We were making a full screen iPod.
And the full screen iPod
was we were playing videos
at the time on the iPod,
but it was in a smaller screen.
Then over in the world of the Mac,
they were making multi-touch technology.
All three of those things
came together over time
to create what we know as the iPhone.
- Today, we're introducing
three revolutionary
products of this class.
- [Joanna] By January 2007, it
was ready to show the world.
- A wide screen iPod with touch controls,
a revolutionary mobile phone,
and a breakthrough internet
communications device.
(audience cheering)
These are not three separate devices.
(audience cheering loudly)
This is one device
and we are calling it iPhone.
(audience cheering)
- My group that I worked with,
we were all big Mac fanatics.
Every one of us, our
jaws just hit the floor.
We're like, this is the
coolest thing we've ever seen.
I knew I had to have one. (chuckles)
- [Joanna] But instead of standing in line
for that very first iPhone,
Jason Schmick grabbed his digital camera,
iPod, and Blackberry
and headed to the birthing center
right after he fired off
an email to his colleague.
- Well, I titled it Red Alert.
"It looks like the iPhone
isn't the only thing
being released today.
I will not be in today.
Lauren went into labor last night."
- [Joanna] Around 6:00 PM in Madison,
the iPhone and Noah were
released to the world.
- [Jason] Here he is everyone.
Noah Harrison Schmick.
- Was there anything surprising to you
as the phone gets out into the world
about how it starts to be used?
- The culture at Apple
changed dramatically.
Because the people who had them,
they were always messaging
or they were always emailing.
When people were in the meetings,
they were doing this all the time.
It became a constant deluge
of emails and messages.
And you were like, "Oh my God,
no one could get off of them."
And you were like,
something's different here.
- [Joanna] But messaging,
phone calls, and music
weren't the end game.
What came next really changed things.
- As we arrive at iPhone's first birthday,
we're gonna take it to the next level.
And today we're introducing the iPhone 3G.
(audience cheering)
- The year I got my first iPhone was 2008
and it was the 3G.
- So it looked something like this.
- Oh my God, yes.
(laughs) I forgot how
curved the bottom was.
- [Joanna] The second iPhone
had a faster 3G connectivity.
That speed combined with
a new software feature
turn the iPhone into
something more than a phone.
- [Voiceover 6] There's an app for that.
In 2008, the iPhone 3G
brought faster 3G networking
and the revolutionary App Store.
- [Joanna] Greg Joswiak
was part of a small team
Steve Jobs tasked with rolling
out the iPhone to the masses.
He now leads marketing for Apple.
- You know, the other great
innovation was in 2008.
It was the App Store.
That is what created this massive
set of things that is what
changed our lives, right?
They didn't all just come from us.
They came from what we did
to empower developers.
- When I joined Apple in March 2009,
there were roughly about 8,000,
6,000 apps submitted per week.
I mean, it grown quickly.
- [Joanna] Oh yes, the store exploded
beyond Apple's expectations.
And so the company hired
Phillip Shoemaker to oversee it.
- 2008 Christmas, one developer
made a million dollars
and that issued
a gold rush to everybody
and developers started submitting in mass.
When the App Store launched,
Apple actually expected maybe 500 apps.
By April, we were at 25,000 apps per week.
- [Joanna] There were all kinds of apps.
Ones that would turn your
phone into a flashlight,
a restaurant critic,
a personalized DJ,
and loads that would, well,
turn your phone into a babysitter.
- We started to hand Noah the phone
shortly after the twins came along.
So he was two, maybe three.
Be entertained for a
minute at a restaurant
or I am breastfeeding.
He knew where the page of games was
that he was allowed to play.
And even if it was a hit the chicken
and it makes a chicken sound
(chicken clucks)
to him that was the greatest
thing in the whole world.
- I never thought that
kids apps would take off.
The iPhone was,
for those of us that have been
in the phone space for a while,
seemingly kind of difficult to use, right?
People didn't understand how to swipe,
how to input text, et cetera, et cetera.
But I was wrong.
- [Joanna] The days of bringing toys
and books and crayons to
the restaurant were over.
Now, games and apps were just a tap away.
But that instant gratification
had some unforeseen and
expensive consequences.
- In 2009, late 2009, my
daughter's five years old.
Her name is Miley.
She started playing Smurfs a lot.
About a month later, we realized
that she had purchased
$450 worth of credits,
Smurf berry.
(coins clanking)
So we instituted something
we called the Miley rule,
which was a feature in
the operating system
that allowed the parent
to turn off purchases,
saying requires a password every time.
- [Joanna] By the time Noah's
generation was four or five,
they were immersed in digital worlds
that almost felt real.
As for the real world,
big leaps in the iPhone's camera
were starting to give them
a whole new way to see it.
- We set out to create an all new phone,
a camera in the iPhone 4S.
We didn't set our sights
in just making it better
than every other phone.
We've already done that.
We set our sights on competing
with the quality of many
great point and shoot cameras.
(upbeat music)
(Lauren laughing)
- This is one part where you like
start really shaking (chuckles) your butt.
There it is.
(Lauren laughing)
- You literally dance like
that for the whole song
and still were not tired.
(all laughing)
I mean, it's your first kid.
You take a photo of him doing anything
and 'cause you think
everything they do is amazing.
I think the other thing that really
kicked it into high gear
for us using the camera
was when Facebook became an app
because that was how we shared
everything with my family.
And my parents wanted to see photos
of our kids all the time.
(magical music)
- [Joanna] With faster uploading
and improved social media apps,
Noah decided he wanted to be
in more than just family photos.
(swoosh loudly)
- I started watching YouTube
when I was like six or seven.
I wanted to be a YouTuber very badly.
- And did you ever try to shoot videos
on your parents' iPhones or your phone?
- Yeah, I would drag my parents out
to record these terrible,
terrible tutorial videos
for just toys I got for holidays.
He's kind of big
even though on the back he's all stuffy.
- [Joanna] But soon, kids
wouldn't even need their parents
to hold the camera anymore.
- The next phone has a front-facing camera
and we are trying to figure out
what do you do with the
front-facing camera?
And you can take a picture
with the front-facing camera.
You take a picture of yourself.
Is that gonna be big?
I don't know.
- It was.
- It ends up being
- Spoiler.
big deal.
- [Joanna] Justin Santamaria
was a senior engineer at Apple
working on iOS and led the team
that launched FaceTime in 2010.
- I remember having the
vice president of iPhone
come to my desk and say,
"Steve wants to see a demo."
It's really funny as
Steve's kind of looking,
he is holding his phone
like this looking down.
And I remember this, he goes,
"I look abominable."
It's ultimately not how
people hold their phones today
for selfies or video calls.
- [Joanna] That's right.
Not even Steve Jobs saw the impact
of the front-facing camera coming.
Noah though, has grown up
surrounded by kids and adults
without stretched arms.
- I do not like to take selfies of myself
because I don't understand
the appeal fully,
but my siblings definitely do.
They take photos of
themselves all the time.
They'll do like an interlocked arm thing
once they can fixture the other one.
- I went on vacation
and you saw people just taking selfies
all day long on vacation
when you're at a resort or whatever,
and they're not enjoying
the world around it.
And you're like, wait a second.
What's going on here?
We are just intermediating reality
with this screen in front of your face.
- I think it's just,
society has trained them to
take pictures of themselves.
- [Joanna] The iPhone was
no longer just a phone.
It was a powerful, connected
computer with a camera.
But one thing held this device back
from being something we
could do more and more on.
- Today, we are launching
the biggest advancement
in the history of iPhone.
the iPhone 6 and the iPhone 6 Plus.
(audience cheering)
And yes, they're bigger.
They're a lot bigger.
- [Joanna] By 2014, the
smartphone competition was huge.
Literally.
- [Man 1] Check out the screen.
This thing is huge.
- [Man 2] It's pretty massive.
- [Joanna] Android
phone makers, especially
- Samsung.
- Samsung?
- That's says Samsung.
- [Joanna] began packing
as much into these phones
as possible.
And with that, the phones
started getting bigger.
- Would you mind moving
your enormous phone?
- You mean the enormously awesome Galaxy?
- Thinking back at that time,
how big of a factor
was Samsung and Android
as they were hitting the market
with these massive phones?
- They were annoying.
And they were annoying
because as you know,
they ripped off our technology.
They took the innovations
that we had created
and created a poor copy of it
and just put a bigger screen around it.
And so yeah, we were not too pleased.
- [Joanna] Apple sued Samsung
for patent infringement.
And by the end of the decade,
Apple had received hundreds of millions
for the patent violations.
A Samsung spokeswoman said
the company has pioneered
many mobile industry first,
- [Voiceover 7] Even in the rain,
the shower or the pool.
- [Joanna] including large OLED displays
and water and dust resistant devices.
By 2014, Apple finally caved
and the iPhone was now
the size of a Samsung
because Jason and millions of others
saw the benefit of giant phones.
- And yeah, I love this thing, man.
And I said I was never gonna use a phone
with a screen this big.
- [Joanna] Two years later,
shortly after Noah turned 11,
Jason handed that 6S Plus down to his son.
- I was very excited when
I got my first iPhone.
It was probably one of the
happiest moments in my life.
I just remember getting it
and then just running away immediately
to go play stuff.
'Cause a lot of my
experience with phone games
was at that point from
just watching my dad.
- [Joanna] Yes, for Noah, it meant games.
Well, even more games.
He'd already played on his
computer and gaming console,
but now it was always with him,
his very own iPhone.
- Plants vs. Zombies
was a huge one for me.
Minecraft: Pocket Edition,
like a lot of the original
phone games like Flappy Bird.
(bird chimes)
Angry Bird's a huge one.
(glass breaks)
(pig grunts)
- I would say by the time Noah was 10,
he was pretty fully ingrained
in the video game world.
It has never been my favorite thing
and it is something that half of us
have tried to set limits on.
(both chuckles)
- [Joanna] During the late 2010s,
the iPhone not only grew in size
but in processing power.
More power equaled more capabilities.
- On my phone now, which is this one,
I'm mostly just watch
YouTube and listen to music.
I play games and browse Reddit and stuff,
but I don't really use it for phone stuff.
It's just like a small
computer in my pocket.
- [Joanna] After all that
there wasn't much left to do
to make the iPhone more
prevalent in our lives,
well, other than make
it do all those things
for even longer.
- We are so excited to tell you
that with iPhone 11 Pro
you now get up to four
hours longer in your day.
(audience cheering)
And with iPhone 11 Pro Max
up to five hours longer in your day.
(audience applauding)
- Battery life's always
important for a portable product.
We've made it even a bigger
and bigger point of emphasis.
Whether it means making the
silicone more efficient,
our ability to where we can
increase the size of battery
and certainly larger screen,
iPhones allow you to do that.
- Wow.
- [Joanna] Ahead of his 15th birthday,
Noah's parents finally
upgraded his iPhone 6S Plus
to a new iPhone 13.
- This is cool, Dad.
Thank you.
Biggest difference is
definitely battery life.
Like on this phone, I could
probably only play a game
for two hours before
I'd have to plug it in.
This one I can play a
game for an entire day
and still get home after school day
and be at 50% battery.
It's amazing.
It's so much nicer.
- Do you have a sense of how much time
you spend on your phone?
- I feel like not a healthy amount.
- [Joanna] That's Chloe,
one of Noah's 13-year-old siblings
who is especially
attached to her iPhone 12
and apps like TikTok and Snapchat.
- I kind of feel like
I'm always on a device
besides when I go
hanging out with friends.
And even then I'm on my phone sometimes.
But I'm mostly on my phone and stuff.
- [Joanna] Like all of us,
the Schmick's have enjoyed each
of those life changing innovations
that have come along with the
last 15 years of the iPhone.
But now, possibly the greatest
innovation Apple can give us,
limiting how much we use it.
- Screen Time empowers you
with both insight and control
over how you spend your time.
And we think this is gonna
be helpful for many people,
but especially for some kids.
- We use Screen Time a lot
to limit how much time they
get with certain things.
So having it locked down
during the school day
so they're not using it at school,
which they're not supposed to do anyways.
- [Lauren] And at night to force them
- [Jason] Yes.
to actually go to sleep.
- Yes, they just simply don't work
between the hours of nine to 6:00 AM
or something like that.
- We try.
You know, we're always, Chloe, especially,
we definitely get a lot of time requests
throughout the day.
♪ Okay, all right ♪
♪ It's about damn time ♪
- [Lauren] And usually
followed by a text message
that says, "My teacher
said I can have 15 minutes.
Can I please have 15 minutes?"
- Here we go.
That's pretty.
- I've been talking to a child
who was born on June 29th, 2007.
This is him.
- Oh!
- That's his picture from June 29th, 2007.
- Taken with the iPhone?
- Not taken with the
iPhone as you'll learn,
but,
- Bummer.
- this is something he said to me
during our interview a couple weeks ago.
He says, "This is everything
you would ever need
in the palm of your hands.
Why would you ever be off of it?"
Is that what you hope to hear
or does some part of that
make you feel uncomfortable?
- It's mixed, right?
We've created an incredible tool
to help people with how they learn
and to help people how they work.
To help people with how they communicate,
how they're entertained.
It's a powerful tool.
But at the same time
we wanna help people with the fact
that there's moderation needed.
But we don't make our
money off engagement.
There's no like, more you use your iPhone
the more money we make.
That isn't the way it works, right?
We just want you to have
this great experience
and sometimes that does mean
you gotta temper how
much you're gonna use it.
You gotta moderate how
much you wanna use this.
- Have you seen this with
some of your own kids?
- We all have concerns around social media
and the effect on kids.
My younger daughter, yeah, no,
she and I have talked about it
and she goes through periods
where she's using it too much
and then scales herself way back.
(light music)
- Truly, we just thought this was gonna be
a fun, easy to use thing when
you wanna do a few messages.
Didn't think it was gonna
become the center of your life.
- [Lauren] We have burgers,
we have fries kind of.
We have, I don't think there's asparagus.
- [Noah] There is, there is.
- There we go, all right.
- [Joanna] After 15 years
of living with the iPhone,
we now have to figure out
how to live with it less.
- In theory, we have a no
phones at the table for dinner.
- [Joanna] If we've learned
anything from all this
it's that our individual willpower
is only challenged by increasing
technological advancements.
- It's always amazing
that every time you think
it's as good as it can get,
we always try, manage a
way to make it better.
- But if and when that better thing comes,
will we control it
or will it control us?
- Thank you for cooking.
- [Chloe] Thanks for cooking.
- As I've grown older,
I've gotten way, way, way
more into these things
as so as the rest of the world.
They've gotten a lot better
and they're gonna keep
getting insanely good.
Taking away screens is like
taking away my friends.
No one can stop you from being
on your phone at all times
besides your own self-discipline.
(light music)